the star trek convention has taken over  valleys on the strip and what better  place for our own george knapp to  connect the show to his expertise on  ufos star trek visionary science fiction  a view of the future alien worlds alien  civilizations and ufo world which was  seen as even more fictitious than star  trek was now those two worlds i think in  the last  five or six years have sort of come  closer  so george was on hand for a screening of  a documentary centered on bob lazar he  once worked on what we now know as area  51 and george was the first to bring  lazar stories into the public eye george  will be back at the convention tomorrow  alongside filmmaker jeremy corble to  talk about the ufo discoveries made  public in the last few years